[Music]
welcome back so we've talked about a
number of examples of data major data
matrices X for example where each column
is a human face or some physical system
evolving in time like flow field
measurements from a fluid flow there's
another example I like to use that I use
in class sometimes to illustrate this
idea of correlation structure within the
data and that's the example from the
Netflix prize and so the Netflix prize
was essentially a 1 million dollar prize
to the team that could come up with the
best prediction algorithm to recommend
movies that users would enjoy watching
they would vote highly if they were
presented with this movie and so they
have a big data matrix - okay and the
way we might think about this is that
each column vector of the Netflix data
matrix would be all of the movie
preferences for person 1 so this is
person 1 person 2 and so on and so forth
p.m. maybe and then each row would
correspond to a specific movie this
would be movie 1 movie 2 and so on and
so forth and so this is a very very very
large matrix you know there might be a
hundred million people in the Netflix
that subscribe to Netflix and there
might be a hundred thousand movies in
the library okay and so this would be a
hundred thousand five hundred million
dimensional matrix and each entry would
be that particular person's rating of
that particular movie okay so they're
hypothetically if a person watched all
of the movies in the Netflix library
they would have some affinity for some
they would dislike others and there
would be a rating for each of those
movies that's what this vector a column
vector represents is that particular
person's preference or dislike for every
single movie in the library
now what's interesting is that this
matrix is actually very sparsely
populated Netflix asks its users to rate
a handful of movies that they've watched
and maybe each user will rate 10 or 20
or 30 movies out of this you know
hundred thousand movie database and each
person will rate different movies so
maybe I ring I rate these tens someone
else rates another ten and so on and so
forth so the vast majority of this
matrix is actually missing and the
Netflix prize is essentially designed to
fill in all of the missing values of
this matrix to pinpoint which movies you
haven't seen that you would like to see
okay that you would enjoy seeing and the
entire idea of what makes this work is
the fact that this matrix has dominant
correlations among the columns and among
the rows I'm going to walk you through
that very briefly so even though we all
like to think of ourselves as unique
with our own unique preferences and and
tastes it turns out that you know if you
if you took the SVD if if all of the
values were filled in and you took the
SVD of this matrix there would still be
relatively few dominant patterns in
terms of eigen tastes of people's movie
preferences maybe there would be ten
maybe there would be a hundred but there
certainly wouldn't be a hundred million
important unique profiles okay
maybe you have people that like action
movies and Marvel superhero movies maybe
you have people that like you know
romance and comedies maybe some people
like all of them but those might be kind
of your principal components similarly
movies themselves have a lot of dominant
correlations in terms of what people
like about them you have your action
movies your romances your comedies and
so on and so forth and so for example if
person one likes The Terminator and
alien and I liked Terminator probably I
will also like alien or at least that
that's the kind of idea that would be
going on here is that you could use
correlations among the people among the
columns and correlations among the
rose to discover what would be the
hidden or missing values that have not
been filled in here okay now you can't
use the singular value decomposition
off-the-shelf to fill in all of those
missing values if you had the complete
data matrix you could find the patterns
and use them but this matrix you know 99
or 99.9% of these values are missing and
so you have to fill those in assuming
that there's a low rank singular value
decomposition that exists for this
matrix and so this actually motivates
what we're going to discuss in chapter 3
of the book on sparsity and compression
and robust statistics is this idea that
you can build what's known as a robust
principal component analysis
remember that PCA is going to be built
on the singular value decomposition and
what we can do is build this robust
version of principal components that's
robust even if you have lots of missing
values in this you could fill in those
missing values assuming that their
structure using this robust principal
component so we'll talk about this in
Chapter three later even if a user
decided to be a jerk and just you know
randomly answer all of those questions
that Netflix is asking to try to mess up
the algorithm with this robust
dimensionality reduction you could kind
of remove that user and D bias the
results if most of the other people are
being honest okay so it's one of my
favorite examples that the big big
matrix it's a real problem I mean this
was a million-dollar prize to solve this
problem where you fill in based on
correlations people's preferences and
it's a modified robust variant of the
singular value decomposition that we've
been talking about okay thank you